From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
This is Emilye Crosby on December 3rd, 2015 with Mrs. Leesco Guster in her home in Port Gibson, Mississippi.
We are here with the Civil Rights History Project, which is co-sponsored by the Library of Congress in the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
Also here are John Bishop and Guha Shankar.
Thank you very much, Mrs. Leesco Guster, for joining us for letting us come to interview you today.
Could you start by telling us when and where you were born?
Port Gibson, Mississippi.
In fact, straight down on, they call it Main Street.
I think the little house, it might be gone now, but I was born right across from the Health Department.
That's a good location.
That's all I can say.
Down the whole across from the Health Department.
Did your mother have a midwife?
Yeah, midwife.
What was your born?
March 26, 1936.
What was your tell us about your family and growing up?
Well, mostly I had a single mom at the age of about six.
She left and went to Vicksburg, Mississippi.
So later she got me.
That's why we lived in Vicksburg, Mississippi.
She and my father separated.
What kind of work did your mother do?
Pardon me?
Domestic work.
And what was your schooling like?
What were the schools like you went to?
Well, sort of like these.
You started one, you go so far like at Magnolia.
In Vicksburg, Mississippi, I went to the fifth grade.
Then I had to go over to Mac and Ty and go to the eighth.
Then you had to go back to Mac know you to go to the tenth.
Really?
Why didn't you go back?
I mean, how did they just...
That's how the grades were running.
At those schools during that time.
Did you like school?
I liked it.
Yeah.
Did you have a favorite subject?
I was kind of lazy.
I like home hit.
I never did any of the kind of sports.
Yeah.
What was poor Gibson like in those days?
Well, I didn't come here to live until 1953.
Okay.
I came now here.
So since you were living in Vicksburg, Mississippi when you came to poor Gibson,
did it seem like a little small town to you?
Well, it wasn't too often that I came now here.
But I thought it was...
At that time it was fine.
But now it's kind of, you know, on the dead side.
But at that time I thought it was blooming.
Can you describe what it was like in those days?
In poor Gibson?
Well, number one, they call it...
Back then they called it Negro Street.
Joints were all up and down the street.
People standing around,
stalled up and down the street.
But all of that left.
That's fair street, right?
That's fair street.
It was a busy...
It was busy.
You could hop from one dough to the next one.
Did you like going over there?
Yeah, I was young at that time.
I was young.
You were saying at that time...
That street...
The people were alive.
You drink what you want.
I wasn't a big drinker.
But I sure liked to eat.
And then you go eat?
Where would you eat on a fair street?
We each had one cafe called Peaches.
She had good food.
Yeah.
Lara Kelly, young.
What's your first memory of being aware of race?
And segregation?
Well, really and truly...
I guess all along just by, you know, instinct.
But see, at that time it didn't bother me.
Yeah.
I just had to do domestic work and stuff like that.
But as I grew older and stuff, I just...
I've just felt like we need to change.
Such as colored bar from colored desk, colored fountain...
And white fountain.
And I don't think that she would be in.
I don't think she would be in.
But man, you...
I got along with him.
I did.
In fact, I lived in Scofield, North.
I lived with this since then.
But I stayed in the house, not the basement.
Which white people?
You were working for them?
I was.
Yeah.
And when did...
You went to Chicago in the 50s?
50...
Of course I came back here around 50 years old.
How did Chicago compare to Mississippi?
It didn't.
You worked yourself to death.
Yeah.
You get up at night.
I had to hop air from the air to the bus trying to get...
Get from place to place.
And when you leave this dog, when you come back, it's still dog.
So you had a time for nothing too much.
Because even on Sundays, they would pay something like extra.
And if I had a chance to work on Sunday, I worked.
That was at Montgomery Ward.
So when you first went, you worked for a family?
I lived on premises, Scofield and all.
And then you went to work for Montgomery Ward?
Well, a month, I didn't work.
Maybe two months, because I got sick.
Because I liked the job.
But my nerve got on edge and I didn't know who was happening with me.
But I had to stop working.
And that's when I started going, really, day work.
Now, that's where you work.
You do a week's work.
Everything, be waiting on you when you get there.
The nice one would have some knee pads.
But you want to know something?
I started cleaning floors on my hand, especially a tile.
My self, right here in Port Gibson, nobody told me.
Did they really?
I did it myself.
You told me you started your first job pretty young here.
I did.
Did you like working?
Did you burn?
No, I was about 16.
Yeah.
I see.
In fact, I had a house, I had my own house at 16.
Did you really?
She was getting my social security check.
She'd bring that to me when it come.
And Mrs. Bear.
She was the one who furnished the house for me.
She was the one who bought me clothes and stuff,
so I had no problem.
When you said Ms. Bear, she was the mayor's wife.
Uh-huh.
And you made a reference to she.
You talked about your sister, right?
When you say she would bring you
your social security check.
That's who's getting my check, my sister.
Your sister?
Yeah.
Lindsay Roof.
You've always been Lindsay Roof.
That's her name.
You've always been independent.
I have.
Yeah, I have.
So were you happy to move back to Port Gibson?
I was.
But I guess I might would have still been there.
When I left, I left for a reason.
I was leaving.
The person that I came back and married.
You couldn't get away from him.
I didn't come right away.
I gave him a year to think about it.
And tell me about your husband who you married.
Well, he was something like 24 years older than I was.
And he was handsomain, you know, nothing short about him.
And he was the head contractor in the Lumber, you know,
field here in Claiborne County,
and vice-president everybody knew Harry.
He was contractor.
So when you came back and you married,
Mr. Harry Guster, did you all stay?
Was this your house then?
It was.
He had the house when I came, you know?
Did he build it?
No, no.
It really wasn't a house when I came.
It was a sec.
He paid something like $2,500 for it.
And when I came, you just, you wouldn't believe.
You could stand on the front and look up under the house
all the way back.
OK, this hall goes straight on back.
What an old bathroom inside.
He stuck it where he could, because it
was having no money or anything at that time.
We had to put it close to where the pipes went stuff were.
So I would never have thought that.
And it didn't get like this when he was living now.
It's been since he had been dead that I did a whole lot of work.
It's kind of ironic since he was a builder, right?
The only thing about it, he did some,
but the whole house, it was just one of the house, you know?
But the lumber and things still good and whatnot.
And he did what he could with the finance he had.
And so I think we were just looking at your birth certificate.
You got married.
I'm not birth certificate.
Marriage.
You got married in like 1959.
Yes, and then.
And when you came back here and married Mr. Gustav,
were you working then?
I'm done with what?
I came back here on a three-week vacation.
And I told him that I would, you know, he know what he had done, you know?
Told me he was already married and wasn't married.
I was 19 when I left here.
And I told him I wouldn't come back here unless he married me.
And if he didn't marry me, you know, I was going back within that three weeks.
I was going back because my job was waiting on me.
And he had told me he had put in for the divorce.
And done everything.
He had gone and talked to a lawyer.
He hadn't paid nothing.
And I told him I was going back to Chicago.
I hate that I did it in a lot of instances because that he had a son and that calls friction.
And he was, you know, under age time.
So his ex-wife, you know, was so sure that he was going to take him back like he did
before when he was, they wouldn't marry that time.
They didn't marry until I went to Chicago.
But he didn't do it.
So I had a problem with the child.
Did you stay with you all?
A lot.
That must have been a challenge.
It was a big, big, big change, especially when the mother, you know, put the child up.
Two things.
But anyway, he got busy when I told him I was going back and I bet you he went to see
a lawyer then.
He didn't have to convince you to stay.
He did.
Yeah.
And he was always, you know, fair with me about his child too.
You know, he saw what was going on.
He didn't know about his (child) support, but (he sent) me to her every month.
Did you really?
Yeah.
Could the courts require that back then or did you just do it because you thought it was
right?
Oh, hallelujah.
Yeah.
You know, way back down to $25 was a lot of money.
That was a lot of money.
And he couldn't guarantee no work in the one-a-tab.
And it wasn't anywhere in a decree where he didn't have to pay.
If he wasn't working, he ever heard of such.
He still, we were barring money to pay even for my sick mama, you know, everything.
And finally, we had to pay our lawyer to change it around where he didn't have to pay.
If he wasn't working.
So he changed after $25 a month.
I told him, I'm not going to be around here while you're fighting a lawsuit.
I said, you better do it.
I was just pushing him on.
He said, all you came back for $30.
I said the same thing I pushed him and he beat it.
Then the next time, $30,000 in advance,
when she took their (s)on over to Jackson to his brother's house,
left him and went on to Cleveland, Ohio.
But that $30.
But asked me this, she didn't get to next $30.
That was it.
She wasn't taking care of his son.
That's right.
You told me at one point that you worked for Mr. Walk-Cut?
Oh, yes.
Can you tell us about, I've been a lot of people don't know about Rabbit Foot Minstrels.
Can you tell us about that?
I can tell you anything about Rabbit Foot Minstrels.
Her or you used to work around Mr. Walk-Cut and also drive him around.
That's how I got acquainted.
He wouldn't let me work.
But he let me work for Hillary when she moved here from Adena, Ohio.
What was her name?
Hillary?
Okay.
And so because of his relationship with Mr. Walk-Cut, he let me work.
And she was his sister?
Oh, his daughter.
His daughter?
Oh, I forgot that.
Her daughter.
Yeah.
And you were doing domestic work at her house.
Did you all get along well?
Very, very much so until her friends got to her house.
She was driving my car.
I had a 1965 and been a long time.
A Catalina stopped making a Catalina Pontiac.
And I had a key to the house.
Now, my new app was not even a member of the NAACP.
My thing was, I wanted to vote.
I wanted to get people registered to vote.
I wanted a little recognition and a better job.
I may not get it, but somebody else come along.
So every evening, when I get off, I would go up there
about what's their drugstore name, McFatter's.
That's where Rudy Shields and all of them hung out.
And because I wasn't even going to the meetings.
But I got acquainted with Rudy.
And I grew all over the Claiborne County in canvassing.
You know, after the federal, people came in to vote.
And the people would see me standing out there.
So they got to her.
It wasn't like, when I was no secret, I had done my work
at the house and everything.
So I don't think you can take your job home with you.
One more now. I was there.
I noticed the change before that particular moment.
She didn't know I was there because I didn't drive up that wall.
And she came in with a, saying a few chores words.
I don't even remember who she was talking to.
And whether she was going to, you know, I can't use the term she used.
And then she saw I was there.
She said, well, Lee, we don't need you anymore.
I support Thank you.
And I left walking because I didn't drive up that day.
That was it.
But she came from Ohio and joined in with the people here in Claiborne County.
So she has a different attitude until she's getting with them.
So you're not going to use her words.
But what was she basically saying?
What was her point to her friends?
She was tired of all that damn shit.
That's what she said.
And she's talking about the voting?
She was talking about them coming to her and me.
I never stopped going up there.
You know, every evening I would go up there and we can just bring in people
to, I wore out a set of tires I can tell you.
So you said at first you weren't an NAACP member and you weren't even going to the meeting.
You were a voter register.
Were you aware of it?
Did you know?
I knew about the meetings and stuff.
I knew all about that.
But like I said, I was interested in getting people to register and vote because that vote and that dollar was what matter.
As far as I'm concerned.
And that's what I was about.
And I wasn't about no all white.
And I wasn't about no all black.
And I...
When she came up there talking to you.
She didn't tell me.
She was talking to me.
I don't even remember who it was.
So if she was, I don't know.
But I heard her.
So I said, well I didn't get it.
I didn't go.
Well, you could tell.
It was fired up.
When she said she couldn't use you anymore.
Well, she was polite in saying that.
But I heard all she had to say.
So you would go around by Mr. McFatter's and that's where the federal administration was.
They were upstairs with Dr. Barnes.
Okay.
And how did you meet Rudy Shields?
On the street in front of the drug stop.
Did he start talking to you?
Tell us what he was like.
Brave.
Wasn't scared of nothing.
I don't know how to explain Rudy except he...
He just...
He wasn't radical.
But he just spoke up of what the things that he knew.
You know.
And...
He was doing what I wanted to do.
I tried to get people register.
So I volunteered my car.
And my hood was going to...
45.
That was a suit.
My gun or something.
It would leave me shoot.
It skipped.
I didn't know that.
You're reliant on it.
He was reliant on it.
No, Rudy.
He was living.
But I didn't let him go out there.
See, he was sickly.
And I didn't let him march or anything.
Because, you know, if he had gone to jail,
then that wouldn't have been good or far.
Did he want to be involved, didn't he?
He was interested.
He wanted to be involved.
Oh, he was involved.
Yeah.
He went to all the meetings.
The people stayed here in the house.
He slept back there and I slept up here.
And I was shot gone.
Staying up, making sure.
Yeah, it wasn't comfortable at all.
Looking back, I wouldn't do it again.
No, you wouldn't.
I wouldn't do it.
Number one, I'm old.
And I don't have a husband.
I wouldn't take it on.
Then, you don't have anybody to back you up now.
Like in a legal way, you get in jail.
You could be sure you're going to get out.
Because, you know, they won't have a lawyer's thing.
And the people who come up to go, but nobody's going to trust
putting their property and stuff up.
Well, for what?
Maybe I better not say this.
But, you know, we don't have anything about it to back us here
in Claiborne County, believe me.
But at the time, did you hesitate?
Did you have any hesitation back in the 16th?
About standing here.
About them staying here, about doing voter registration.
No.
No, no, no, no.
I don't know where it came from, but I was brave.
Yeah.
What about Mr. Harry Guster?
Was he working when you were doing the movement?
Well, for why?
How then?
He was being spurred, Louisiana, and put you in some of those
of the places, mostly, where he worked with nobody.
We lived out of the A-check, $114 a month.
Back there was a lot of money.
I was a little hundered, had to go to the bank on the car.
And $43-and-cents.
So security check, because he really hadn't paid into it.
You know, he paid for his workers, but he hadn't paid it and
he was paying into it too much.
So he lost all his work, I lost all my work.
The $20 a week work, but I was getting from Hill Wall car.
Was that a hardship for you all?
Was it a hardship?
Back then, you know, you could take a little nut and make it.
If you know how to do it.
You could do it.
Well, tell us, good money.
I know he came into the area with Charles Evers.
He did.
From Chicago.
Did he talk about Chicago at home or why he came?
He didn't have time to talk about nothing.
But whether he came here to do, he didn't have conversations.
Now, he stayed here, but long enough to sleep.
And that's about it.
What would he say about why he was, you know,
what he wanted to do here when he was trying to accomplish?
What he said was said at, you know, different meetings and things.
It wouldn't be a personal thing.
Was he quiet?
Like I said, he slept here.
I feed him, you know, in the morning.
I wouldn't send him over tonight that he eats somewhere else, you know.
So when you and Rudy would go out,
and listen for a voter registration,
tell us what that was like.
Well, we had people, you know,
over the people and things who didn't understand.
They wouldn't worry about voting or anything,
because we had never done it before.
We had never done it.
And some would go with us, and some wouldn't, you know.
But we, that didn't stop.
We go keep on, you know, going.
Was it, did you try to convince people?
Well, yeah.
We tried.
But mostly the people who live on plantations, they were afraid.
They were free.
Does he need one?
What's that?
Oh, okay.
Okay, we're back.
Did you ever run into any trouble or any problems when you were registering people?
Oh, yeah.
Rocky Springs.
I know we'll forget that.
We went out there.
It was two trails, right together.
Now, I'm telling the story.
It was one trail.
It was kind of long.
And they told us to come back the next day.
Well, when we got back, the owner of the property was,
and a pickup truck was parked up on the hill.
And he had his shot go.
You know, how they have it across the back of the truck.
And I told him, I call him Mr. Shields.
I said, Mr. Shields.
I said, he got it going.
He said, that's all right.
Mr. Harry Guster.
That's what he called Mr. Harry Guster.
He said, we're not doing anything wrong.
So, the man got out of his truck and came over where the people were standing.
We don't want to lose what us got.
You know, Mr. Shields said, well, what do you have?
Well, we got what us want.
And then he said, what he said.
Then, that's when the owner approached.
And he said, it's something from the law that we had a right to go on a private property
and ask people to go registered about.
And when we left there, he beat us out.
And there's one way bridge.
I never will forget that.
And he was parked right on the side.
Rudy was in the back of my car with the sheep and the shooting pistol.
And I said, he was going to be like, you know, one cent straight up.
I said, here they are.
He up here by this bridge.
I said, what you going to do?
He said, Mr. Harry Guster, you just drive.
I said, well, don't I have to do it?
Keep this touch.
I was scared to death.
I'm not going to laugh.
And so, but he didn't do anything.
We went on bad.
He still sent up in his truck.
But that was my scariest time.
I was scared.
Did you worry about going on and going out the next day?
Oh, we went out.
We went out.
We didn't go back there.
You know, those people wouldn't go with us.
Yeah.
I went all the way.
And when you said people were staying at the house, who was staying at the house?
Where we went.
No, at your house when you would keep people at your house.
Civil rights lawyers.
It was an African girl, a stadium, or for months.
Tucked Tate.
She was so sweet.
Did you know Tuck?
And just different people.
You know, and I had nothing to do with being the house in chairman.
They had all of that.
All the nights, Lily Mae Williams was the chairperson.
They had my wells.
I know you remember her.
She was the cold chair.
But anytime somebody needs somewhere to stay, we don't have in the room.
You know, they didn't ask anybody to take them.
So we took them.
We had as high as three.
We had to put them.
They beat up.
Civil rights lawyer.
You know.
So I said, you know, my husband was four.
So we did it.
And we didn't get any money for it now.
Although, you know, I have people at all.
They said that we were getting called here on a tom.
Now after we went through all of that.
We were slipping around to George Ellis.
I think that's where the shoes go.
We closed up.
Now here, the shoes had been there for years and years and years.
But Harry's slipping around and buying shoes.
I was getting paid for hauling people to the pole.
You know, you're not a people talk.
So it didn't bother me because I knew it was a lie.
And now after three weeks, you know, I did it for three weeks on my own.
You know, during the festival, at times,
they told me.
Some of the new differences are between the ones who gave me a donation.
When we go to the meeting, I would stand up and read the
names off who donated toward gas.
They had me getting paid.
Because you're getting asked money.
For some of your expenses.
For few dollars.
Yeah, not a whole new set of tires.
I know you said at first you were just interested in voter registration.
Had you ever tried to register before or thought about it?
Didn't come about, didn't come about my man.
Being around, I hung around the body shop a lot.
And Mr. Colton, you remember Mr. Colton?
Not, you know, be tall.
And Mr. Jesse Johnson.
But I never would have made it if I had gone up to the courthouse.
I had to get registered, I don't believe.
Did you know anybody who was registered before the movement started?
Uh-huh.
Yeah, uh, Mr. Colton, Ms. Colton, Nate John,
Jessie Johnson, uh, uh, what is Johnson main out?
Another Johnson main out there at Patterson.
He was registered?
Oh, I know.
Roscoe.
That's him.
Junior Jones.
So all those people's registered.
But you know, you could almost count on both hands.
How many blacks was registered?
I can't remember anybody, but I'm sure those.
People were registered.
You said when the lady you worked for, when she was talking about,
she wasn't going to stand for this mess, you said at that point,
you weren't going to mass meetings, but did you start going to mass meetings?
I did.
And John.
And John, and of Lesley B.
And I did wrong in one way.
choir practice would be every - every two weeks.
That's when I had to meet.
So I didn't go to, I didn't go to a quad practice.
Therefore I couldn't feel my dues.
I wouldn't do it now, because that's wrong.
And I know this wrong.
But at the time, I didn't care about choir and nothing else.
I didn't.
Can you explain why it was?
I didn't want to miss it.
You know, after rooted, organized the youth, then he put me over.
And so therefore I had to be there with the children, you know.
I didn't worry about choir or nothing.
So I put the Lord behind there, but I never do it again.
What were you doing with the young people?
They were the young people singing, you know, the freedom songs and stuff like that.
And then I even took them to church several times and let the choir sign.
What were they singing?
What were some of the songs?
The freedom song.
I ain't gonna let nobody turn me around.
Then all freedom.
And what else?
He's got the whole world in his hand.
And I can't remember all of them.
Was James Miller and Carolyn?
Well, James, I remember James well.
Yeah.
What was he like then?
And they were just children under me.
So, you know.
Did everybody like the singing?
Was that a highlight?
Well, I mean, there was part of the meeting.
Every Tuesday night.
Viral growth.
Yeah.
What else besides the singing?
What else was going on in the meetings?
Well, with my group, wasn't too much of anything, but when I asked, Mr. Alberta Colmar,
you remember her?
I asked her to help me.
Then AC Garner came in later, wanted to change the thing around to, I don't know how to
say this.
I wanted to have dances and stuff, which I didn't go for.
You know, those people interested their children to us.
And they said what was going to be happening, you know, with that stuff up there, they called
it.
But, you know, they want to have a damn light up there, cause, plays, all this.
I'm in town.
Yeah.
What were the mass meetings like in addition to the, you know, what else would happen besides
the singing at the mass meeting?
Well, what I didn't like, and one of the things kind of pushed me aside, they took the
pool pitch for a play place.
I didn't feel like it should have been that way.
They'd get up there.
The youngsters now, like, do you remember?
I call him, he did.
Dad and I, too, all of a book.
Do me a, a, this is real name.
I don't even know his real name.
Do me.
Everybody call him Do me, but he stopped me from calling and do me.
But he got up there one night, up in the pool, and I was over him.
Over him.
He got up there in the pool.
And we going, beating on the driver.
And I wasn't doing right myself, but I didn't go up in the pool pitch.
But you weren't doing that.
You know, that was just out of, just that plum out of all of it.
Who was that?
Oh, go ahead.
Uh, then, Reverend Dawson, it didn't feel comfortable about it.
That's when he stepped down, and that's when I followed.
Yeah.
You know, and Miss Wales.
Um, she talked about how Reverend Dawson stopped.
You know, I said he had better stopped, or else he would not have been respected in his
pool pitch, from none of the churches, you know.
You know, you don't, you don't play that stuff in God's house now, and like that.
Who are some of the good speakers?
I know you were quiet.
You were very quiet.
Well, uh, they were my Wales.
That's what she did.
It spoke.
She could speak.
Uh, Miss Julia Jones, Jenny Eber Collins, you talked about Rion and here in town, right?
Yeah.
And Mr. Nate was, he tried to talk, but he was kind of stumbling, like I was.
You two were the workers.
Uh, um, uh, what's his name, Kevin?
Kevin, Widgen, he was a good speaker.
But he was on the radical side.
What was he pushing for?
I thought we were pushing for the same thing, but I found out on the second floor,
like I've told anybody that the, I mean, I was in Jackson with Harry.
Had I been here, I wouldn't have gone along with a second boycott, because I didn't
feel like it was fair to the people who had done what we asked.
Now, what they should have done was tighten down on Claiborne Hardware, P.G.
Wigley and folks who had not done.
I wouldn't have followed it.
And the stuff would rip, rip, and walls, and doing stand-out, they would have signed,
and people walking in a stone in a time, they wanted to wall.
That one they'd factor.
Now, in the first go around, didn't nobody go to no stone.
What happened if they did?
Well, you know, uh, what didn't nobody go?
Yeah.
What were the issues for the first boycott?
And I wasn't one of those people who made the plan, you know, but it was a list of them,
and they included like, what I was talking about, about going to vote, recognition, and
put your daughter, sister, I was still, and put one of us on the cash register.
Lo and the whole, when we got old too, that's who we put all that up.
Now, Mark came in, uh, his friends, kids, when he had started, we said that all the job,
that the low income mothers and thing would, when I looked, they were my whales, who
was going to have a, uh, good paying check, because he was service-connected.
My husband was not.
They were my whales, that was social, I could have got a job, matter of fact.
Uh, Mozelle, I had a stone in about four workers, all black.
You know, you know, you just look around and, and you're just not right, I don't care who
it is.
And I don't think they liked it too well.
When I, you know, say how I feel, but that's all right.
Did you ever have any threats at the house?
Oh, yes.
Uh, it was on, we were supposed to have a banquet here, (Charles) Evers came to, ever, um,
she to make it up.
And somebody called here and asked for a hair register.
And I could tell by the accident it was someone, you know, white.
And I said, this is his wife, may I help you?
Because the house was full of people.
And he asked me, was I tired of living?
He identified himself.
He said he was a member of the KKK.
And I was tired of living.
And I said, I can't say what I said.
But anyway, um, he got the message.
Were you afraid?
Well, uh, later on, I was kind after the threat because they threatened to burn this house.
And the Memphis (house/apartment) where Rudy was staying.
And I didn't know what was happening.
We had, it was just one of the law of year that night.
And so they were sitting out there.
My car thing wasn't passing in and we were sitting up under the shed.
And that old building, food stand building about, I didn't realize folks was up on top of
it.
And I looked, this, this, this, all you want to go out to join the other.
And so I gave him no pistol.
And he went out like this.
Like he was going to shoot right there.
And while we were sitting out there, you know, I saw somebody.
He had a hump on the wall.
I said, they looked like Mr. Sheer.
And he went to the colon and made about come back down.
So he didn't want me to know it.
That they had threats out on them.
So, but he had to tell us.
He didn't want to worry you?
Mm-hmm.
Yeah.
And that, you know, a truck came along, some came along and that, like it was going to stop
the night.
I was up here, hairs back there with those shotguns.
And I guess I didn't give it a chance.
You were saying that the truck came by the house that day when you were that night?
That night.
So I thought it was stopping.
And I thought, you know, you get my gun really.
So the next morning, well, I shot the gun, I tell you.
But it was aimed down at the mattress.
And he always put a bullet in the barrel.
And I forgot it was in there.
So I said, well, I can, and the gun was still cocked.
I said, I can let it down now.
But I had it aiming, you know, at the bed, which was good.
And when I, and my husband come creeping out, he was scared to come.
He said, he said, he said, son, son, woman, I thought you had killed yourself.
They said, I did.
So the only fatality was the mattress?
That's it.
Were you out at all form when they had the marches out there?
I was.
And they shot the gas on the spirit.
You know, there's about the marches out there.
I can tell you this.
Now, I only went one time.
That's that one time.
That was enough.
I took the crew out and everything to stay all night.
But we didn't get to stay all night because they put the gas on us.
And that burned your eyes.
So, your house was telling you, put your toe rug at the scene, girl, you stay over
here.
Put your head down in ice cream box.
You know, it said that would stop the burning.
Yeah, it was something that night.
Did anybody get hurt back?
Well, I tell you.
I don't let them, we went home.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I came home.
What?
Perry wasn't there.
I didn't let him go.
You were worried about him.
No, I just, I know that he was sickly and he was on medication.
And I didn't want to be locked up or anything.
What was Mr. Evers like?
Right to the point.
What came up, what happened to the point?
All he did, too, was talk.
Woody was the main one.
Well, we talked to Mr. Nate this morning and he said that you and Woody Shields and
Woody Shields were a chamber of walker, do you know most of the register?
True.
He didn't, we didn't talk about this today, but a number of years ago Mr. Nate told
me that some people thought Rudy was too radical.
Did he?
Yes.
What were they talking about?
What did they think?
Because he wouldn't, he wouldn't take stuff.
Yeah.
(You like) Charles? What came up?
You told me one time that you heard Mr. Hudson talking, like you were going on a march maybe
or something and you overheard him?
Well, what happened?
No, they were met in us.
Oh, okay.
My husband and I had seen Hudson's grocery back.
And he was a record car to cross over there.
Okay.
There's two of that thing.
Before we joined the NAACP, well, that's where we got our gross and stuff and he was talking
to my husband and he was telling us about Harry.
I'm going to do what they asked because the color people is the one who's supposed to
be.
And he was the one who got out there and met us.
And he didn't go in a new store until years after they built.
And everything was over.
And that went off.
Because he didn't have to send up here and this man, this kind of store man, he never
did get to the chance to open because we put him out for a year of open.
Was that Jones?
I think so around that corner.
But I heard he was the one who was trying to bring the clan in the Jones.
And don't mistake yourself.
Some of those with him right from right here.
That's my belief now.
I don't know that.
I remember.
We left Stas where the Federal Register was.
Bobby Gage.
He came up there and made the Federal Register go and move all the cars off the light back
there.
They had parked back there.
He was on his property too, I know.
And he was there.
But nobody used me.
He was the president of what gets me back.
And so he made a move those cars.
And not in a nice way.
Yeah.
Very unpolite.
What was it like during the boycott?
When you get used to it, I tell you what happened to me.
Matt had to store up there.
And I was getting my gas and everything up there.
That's Matt Roth's.
And he didn't put an award in my car.
And I was on my way to Jackson.
A car called on back.
So I had to buy a new motor.
And they checked and see that that's what was happening.
That's one thing I dreaded.
But I would risk this or thing.
We did all right.
We would go to Vicksburg anyway.
Yeah.
Oh, I know what I wanted to ask you.
Can you tell us about the deacons, the blackouts?
They were organized.
It used to be an oak tree was here.
No, it wasn't.
It was out here.
And we had an old green picnic table.
Wouldn't picnic table.
They were organized right out there.
Well, they took care of the business.
You know, when people disobeyed,
they were like, oh, no.
Now, one part of it, I did not like.
And I didn't go for it.
They're shooting in people houses.
I never liked nothing like that.
I don't mind you giving a good scare, but don't shoot.
And that was if people didn't give them over.
They would, they would go into the store and ignore the boycott.
That's what would happen.
They didn't want, they didn't want you,
but they knew not to go there.
Some of them did, they just, they wouldn't mess with people like.
Nanget, Miss Collins, we didn't bother her.
How come?
Because all of a sudden she wasn't black.
She wasn't black.
Kate Bailey on the corner down there on Round Flower Street.
I don't know what she stood for, but she, she stopped.
She didn't go back.
I hope this woman named.
She stayed in Rosem.
Had a pink house and a beautiful glass showcase wonder.
A Priscilla Duck.
That's what it was.
And for that, and the president's from down to Jefferson County,
and the (NAA)CP will stand up there.
And she was here.
I said, you know, that place is boycott.
Don't know about it.
Tell me who had to spend my money.
I saw him right.
So I kind of passed around.
Next thing I know that I didn't know that she was going to stand over.
I got up with my name on it.
She said that she told Miss Custa she was sorry.
She showed it.
So maybe she might have told us.
Nobody's telling her already.
In New York.
I tell my own.
And I did tell her.
But I told her that I said, don't you heard her.
What did she say?
She didn't heard her.
But she scared the devil out.
You all ever talk about that?
She didn't know it.
I didn't tell her.
But she was defeating my purpose.
She still letting the candy man come to our house.
And there my wheels would call me every time.
Because she stayed right across from the candy man at just just outside.
So finally the last time I said, thank you Miss Custa.
Business is not there.
And I went over there and there were the premiums with the gale.
I told her, over and over not to do it.
That's stop I bitch.
So when the boycott, the first boycott was stopped on most of the stores.
What did they agree to?
What made the boycott end?
They put more cuts in there.
Black workers.
And gave them privileges.
And that's when I said it was wrong in them boycotting the people out of business.
Who had done what we asked.
You know, you don't look boycott out or hate out of that and think.
I thought, let's see, that's what can't and seem to be.
Because I said, after the first time, we just accept who said they would run for office.
And I said, well, why don't we ask white person?
And we get behind them and support them.
They give it to me on tape.
You know, I didn't go for that.
I didn't go for that.
Because the white can't do no without us.
And we can't do it without them.
So when I built my school on to my house, I went to Barbiegage, Rob.
You know, Old Man, Old Man, the meat.
And I was missing with them.
And he'd be a project.
Okay.
Cadman, he told me, now, at least, I'm going to be out of town on a meeting.
And if Cadman gets sad, you go to see, you could do your own, help yourself then.
But you could go to the one and ask for money.
And they'd give it without all this paperwork and stuff.
They'd say, go to Mr. Drake and pick the papers up and whatnot.
I went down there to Drake.
It told me it was a question to who my property is since I was in the lawsuit.
Go ahead.
And they didn't give them to me.
So that Monday, when he came back, I went up there.
And the material was still on his desk, where he had written it up.
I thought he was going to bag down.
He said, we're going on with the loan.
Number one, he used his head because he knew if I didn't pay, they had the house.
You see what I'm saying?
And then, too, during that time, Audrey Raine Wai was in the bank
and I heard them talking about it, going to take our house.
And we was behind, and I knew that was the lie because I was keeping up with it.
Because we had gotten behind.
And she was about two or three days later, I received a letter from the law you're seeing that, you know, wanted to see me.
I went up there with all of my receipts.
And sometimes I must have missed place because I didn't know as much as I thought I would.
So which lawyers called you up there?
Which lawyers did you have to meet with?
You said they called you in there?
Bobbi Gage.
He was a lawyer, too.
So because somebody started their rumor, he wanted to make sure...
No, you lived time out taking the house.
You were talking about taking the house.
So see that happened working with the woman.
Yeah, so he's trying to put us out.
And you had all the receipts?
I had all and most of it didn't have one way I had paid or something because I didn't always much as I thought I would when I got there.
So they didn't go anywhere with that?
No, I mean, it was to my advantage.
Yeah, that's what I...
To my advantage.
So they thought they were going to get the house good?
I had...
But had it not been that I pushed my husband on because he didn't go to the banking bar or the money.
No range of shields with Miss Akon.
That's our sister, Miss Shea.
Gave him the $2500.
That's all it calls.
And Harry hadn't paid nothing on it when I came from Chicago.
Not one cop up here.
And I told him, I said, you got to start paying.
So that's what happened.
And before long she got...
Well, she couldn't, you know, be over her own stuff.
And Miss Shea, that came along with her sister.
Miss Akon had given Herra...
He had been in an accident.
And she had given him some money.
She went back and brought that chick up.
Harry had to pay for it.
And I told him, I said, see, they'd be putting us out for real if you hadn't started paying, you know, on your eyes, right?
You mentioned about your property and the lawsuit.
What was the lawsuit about?
Can you tell us?
The move...
I've said we made them lose money.
No, the boy I got.
You didn't do it because you made them lose money.
Uh-huh, boy cop.
And if you weren't in it, they were in it anyway.
When I had to go to court over to Jackson, there was Buster Barber, who worked for Allen Motors.
He was selling cars.
And he didn't have no deals with us.
There was a big-choss, Davis, who was buying the cars.
He was over it.
He didn't have no deals.
If you were black, they'd make no deals.
You might as well go ahead on.
So like, I have people who were in the movement and people who weren't.
That's right.
Somebody told me that they thought they looked at everybody that had property and put their names on them.
Look, they did.
Now, some of them, they looked at, uh, like John, Mr. John Ellis and his wife.
They stayed out.
Kill them away, I think.
Two old people who didn't, you know, do anything.
But they'd go help go bonds for us.
Yeah.
Uh-huh.
So they had them for that.
They put them on the list for that.
I guess so.
You know, in all those years when the lawsuit was going on, did you, did you ever think you were going to win that?
You're going to win it.
Yeah.
You know what?
I didn't really give it too much of a thought.
You didn't.
Because I didn't see how they could do anything like that.
Yeah, for God's sake.
How did I feel when it went to the Supreme Court in 1982?
Well, to me, it wasn't just a little wrong with the judge setting up that.
Yeah.
It wasn't just a really big thing.
Mr. Dan Curry was over there too when I went.
Uh-huh.
And they asked him what race was he?
Are you, are you of the black race or color, the race or what?
He said, no.
I'm Ethel.
You know.
You were describing Mr. (Eddie) Walls' testimony in Claiborne Hardware case when they asked him about his race.
And he said, what do you say?
Oh, Uh-uh-uh, Miss Curry.
Oh, Miss Curry.
Why did I say Wall?
Yeah, Mr. Curry.
He told me he the oatmeal.
And he was proud.
I mean, he was in the honest.
Yeah.
That he felt that way now.
Did you go to a lot of the trial?
Did you go to the trial?
No, I only went when they sent for us.
Yeah.
There were everybody that come in one time.
Did you testify?
What was it like to testify?
Nothing, wasn't too much to say.
Really, if you want the truth.
How can you sue somebody?
Because they lost money that they wouldn't be getting anyway,
because people wouldn't spend it.
Can you finish this one?
Can you tell us what, were you in town
when Nat "Dusty" Jackson was killed?
I was.
Can you tell us about what happened?
I can't tell you, we did march,
but it's something I really had to understand in Nod,
because they wouldn't have felt the aid in one way with us.
So I don't know.
In Tatea too, I didn't see having a march, but they did it.
I hope I'm not saying what I believe.
That's the last truth.
That's all right.
What happened to it, for people who don't already know,
what happened that night?
With Dusty Jackson, what happened at the beginning?
All I know he got killed.
He got killed.
That's all I know.
Did you have anything to do with the school,
this aggregation?
Did you work with any of the children?
No.
So what are some of the things you think are most important
about the movement for people to know?
Well, for one thing, we learned that we could be together
at least for a while in a way.
And I feel like we did a copy of something,
and I also feel like we've lost a lot.
And it's nothing to do with the white people.
It's nothing to do with us.
We don't get along.
Two-minute blacks.
We need black and white together.
Because we're doing the same thing
that they were doing to us.
But I don't believe that they actually would want to come
and work with us because there's so much of mess going on.
We can't get along with each of us.
What were you hoping?
What are some of the things that you hope could happen?
Like, what did you, when you set out,
what were you working towards?
Well, not so much for me,
but there are young people coming along.
That they would have to go through things like we had to go through.
More for the young people.
We've had just about had our day.
Even back then, I was old,
because I was old when I went to school, when I put a cut.
What was it like when the first group of people got elected
for a group of African-Americans got elected to office?
It was fine.
Anybody could have gotten elected.
Everybody was scared.
Some of them didn't have the expertise.
If they did, they'd fear them.
And the other ones didn't have it.
Then they got in.
We were going to put up a man called Theo Black.
That's the reason I was trying to...
I really had thought about Thomas Russell.
I had mentioned that to Mr. Williams,
because they knew that they couldn't win nothing unless we backed him at that time.
What was it about Thomas Russell that made you mention him?
He was just so kind and everything to everybody.
I'm saying that because I believe that's the type of person he was.
He was my backbone and a lot of things.
He was in Catalonia and he said no.
You said if they're going to give it to a wheel of taking.
So he didn't want to work with any white officials?
No.
Did you ever think about running for office?
Not for doll kitchen.
I'm telling you now, you can't satisfy us.
When I said us, I mean blacks.
You got to...
You know there are things that you can't do without the others.
You can only do what you can but you don't have a one vote.
But there'll be things you can do everything and there'll be the biggest mess you'll ever see like it is now.
If you were talking to young people, what advice would you give them?
In terms of what you learned in the movement or what you think they might want to know?
When you speak up for yourself but you can't just sit there and talk, you got to work.
And you are somebody anyway but you can make it better.
You're not saying help.
I'm saying this because I don't want to do anything.
I don't want to do anything.
Have I forgotten anything?
You can look back.
You got my old history from your day to day.
You know, Mr. Day asked me that.
I don't want to get one.
Well, I think he still has and I don't want to take your copy but I'll get it from him.
But I was looking back at the one that you and I did together.
Okay.
You didn't mail it back to me.
But not knowing anything about me had it not been for Nate Jones.
That's true.
I don't want to get all those pictures on the wall up there.
They know who was out there and who was doing what.
And I'm not wanting to get up there and flounce and tell them nothing.
It's just like when Kenneth (Ross) called me and asked me about the mural up there.
He said, would you get me 10 names?
Well, I went way back because of the people that I knew.
But there were no women on there.
He said, I gave them the names.
He said, what about a woman?
I said, can I?
I'm not going to put no lie out there.
I said most of the women that I know was there just talk.
You know, they get up and make good speeches at night and talk about what we ought to do and what not.
But that was it.
And he said, well, what about yourself?
I don't know nothing about myself either.
He said, well, you don't have to.
I said nothing about me.
He said, you don't have to somebody else.
Today, I don't know who did it.
They must have been Mr. Nate, don't you think?
I don't know. You didn't tell me.
Actually, you know what? I think my mom did it.
I think my mom thought too.
I bet a couple people told me that.
I don't know.
Do you like the mirror?
Oh, it's nice.
Is that you right there with Mr. Nate?
They look here, it's still there.
Don't look like me.
I saw him when they were painting it.
You know, look like me.
Did you ever think there would be a civil rights mural in poor Gibson?
No. Let me tell you.
When, um, car, where, that was for something else.
But he had us meeting, talking about, uh, a museum and all of this kind of stuff.
And he even got money.
You know, churches give him money because I took $100 in my church.
And come to find out after he didn't go through it,
he turned it over to the NAACP.
But you don't do stuff like that.
No.
You get it back to where you got it from.
And, uh, I never thought we'd have a mural.
But, Kenneth Ross is smart. He's very smart.
Yeah.
What about the exhibit over in the county building?
Well, the exhibit, the civil rights exhibit?
On inside the courthouse.
Yeah.
Well, they'd do it like this.
They almost sing in and talk.
Yeah.
You know the same thing they did at the meeting.
George Henry, very well deserved.
Reverend Dawson deserves, you know, those people worked.
And then she Reverend Dawson went out there when it was hot.
You know, when you went home, it was, it had cooled down.
And Miss Bellma told me one time, oh, right, Lynn, I see that.
I think I mentioned this though.
Rev. Dawson stepped down.
And, uh, I said, well, he stepped down because of all the mess that was going on.
I didn't mean the NAACP was a mess.
But the mess going on in his church, you know.
And, and it, you call it, she said, you call it a mess.
Look what that mess got you.
I said, I wasn't talking about the NAACP.
You know, I said, well, didn't give me no job.
Nothing first.
And she thought about it.
It got me a job first.
Tell me how he had started, which he did not need.
No.
So I found those people out to be selfish.
Now, Carlos was my friend, close friend.
Margot, we were nowhere around when it was going on.
Soon as she got in town because of who she was, they appointed her president over our mart.
You know, why can't, I mean, we were here doing a struggle.
Why couldn't they get somebody from right here?
You know, we had some people know something because she didn't know, had to bring the Folsom Jackson.
She was smirking all of them.
And I never did.
It was $25.
Sure.
I hate $25, but I didn't buy one.
I didn't buy one.
Did you use the shop over at our mart?
I'd go and then pass my all items.
But it was so hot.
People were trying to go where they could get it cheap.
But I had no bags of this.
So are you proud of what you did in the morning?
I'm proud.
Not am.
But I didn't do it for no show now.
I didn't do it for no show.
I was talking to somebody recently about Rudy Shields.
I can't remember who it was.
I was trying to remember.
Lately?
Yeah.
George used to talk about it all the time.
George thought when Rudy got sick, that I should take him.
I said, George, I can't do that.
I said, this was doing the movement.
I had a husband.
I said, I can't have nobody to seek a man I'm working to.
I had a (husband) - speaker self-correction.
I thought, yeah, well, good friend.
I said, we were good friends during the (time of) doing the movement.
But I couldn't go out there for a while.
I know who it was.
It was a man in Yazoo that he used to stay with.
And it's his daughter.
He's trying to write something.
She's trying to write something about Rudy Sheerl.
She was asking me, so that was good.
We'll discuss it.
Thank you so much for visiting with us and sharing your story.
We're very happy to have it.
And it's the same story.
The same story.
I don't know if we have the way to tell it.
Thanks, Miss Gusted.
This has been a presentation of the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum
of African American History and Culture.